All right, everyone, well, thank you very much for, uh,
for attending 1st,
1st session of the day.
Uh. Uh, my name is
Cheo Alvarez. I'm with Baker Hughes.
Uh, and, and this is how we're driving
energy forward with, uh, with,
uh, with AI technologies in
partnership with AWS.
OK, so
there's a couple of points that I wanna talk on this,
just first,
setting the stage for what the challenges
that we're faced with in energy, I think
in large part driven by the need for
LLMs, agentic, and, and, uh,
and machine learning and the like.
Um,
then we're gonna talk about how we're, how we're approaching
that, um, specifically with our use
and application of agentic.
And some lessons that we've learned
along the way. We've been doing this for a long time. We've
been introducing digital projects into the marketplace
for many, many years. Of course, Agenic is
very new,
but we're trying to weave those into every layer
of our stack to really accelerate
ourselves and our customers' ability to deploy
these, these types of solutions,
um,
really at scale, um, at this point.
So, uh,
a little bit about under the hood, which we're happy
to go into a lot more detail about, uh, uh,
kind of after the session.
Uh, and then looking ahead, where do we see
things going in the future,
um, and so forth, so.
OK, um,
so the energy industry
has, uh, for years
been chasing kind of the same vision of
the digital oil field.
Uh, the, the world's energy demands though
have only accelerated in the last few
years, and, and this is a statistic that amazes
me every time that I see it, but 165%.
Uh, anticipated growth in energy demand
is, is really just remarkable,
driven in large part due to, um,
you know, hyperscaling needs and hyperscaling
energy needs and
Uh, and, and the like. Um,
we have been on a journey in oil
and gas for acquiring
data and, and really appreciating the value
of data, um, at every step of our
operation, from, uh, from the reservoir
to, uh, when we drill and complete a well,
to, um, to how we measure that well,
and then the ongoing operation of that well and
downstream of that.
Um, you can see the statistics that we, we
generate massive amounts of information. Um,
15 petabytes of data coming off of a drilling
rig. There's 1800 drilling
rigs operating at any one time across the
world.
Um, and, and again, that's only the first
part of the process of just drilling the
well to begin with. So, um, so there's,
there's data coming from everywhere,
extracting signal from that noise is
always and forever will be the challenge.
Um, and, uh, but, but the
demand, the, the, the opportunity here is,
is massive, so.
Uh, if you've kind of followed the
energy industry,
um, you know,
when I was first growing up, the story was always
that the world is running out of oil.
It's actually not technically the case.
It's that the world is sort of running out of cheap
oil. And so where we've
risen over and over again to meet that
challenge is introducing new
physical processes to horizontally drill,
to hydraulically fracture, to,
uh, you know, deepwater exploration and
production. Um,
we will continue to do so with
technology. It's just now that this increasingly
so, the technology be, will be more digital
in nature,
um, hence my talk,
so. So
this is uh, this is a quote from McKinsey
about, uh, and, and I think this would
resonate with everybody here, how transformationally
agentic is going to be to every
industry on the planet. Um, it, it's going
to transform every enterprise operations
and, in my opinion, it's gonna make work a
lot more interesting as I can delegate
my menial task to, uh, to
an agent,
uh, so that I can then focus on something,
you know, more creative, higher value added,
uh, and so forth.
Where we see this impacting, this is again very
high level, but 33% of
enterprise software,
uh, will include some shape of agentic
by 2028, again driving
energy demands.
15% of work decisions will be made
by Agentic in 2028. Uh,
over a billion agents are going to be created and deployed
to varying degrees of quality, and, and this is.
Where we see Baker Hughes,
the quality of our agents,
uh, uh, that's really gonna be the competitive
advantage that we see for Baker Hughes and our
ability to help our energy customers going
forward,
um, because
garbage in, garbage out,
um, we have a lot of deep domain expertise
that we need to apply and bring to our,
bring to our agents, so.
Where we have been specifically the
technology area that I work in.
It's called Lucia
and
So Lucipa, let me talk a little bit about
the digital technology program
that I'm a part of, um,
for, because we have been on this journey for years,
um, and the journey that we're on right
now with Agenic is the same journey
that we've taken from day one
with the digital oil fields, so.
The beginning step of the process for us was
we needed to be able to get access to
data,
garbage in, garbage out.
I've heard from every person I've talked to
here, get access to and contextualize
that data,
then. Add workflows, automate
workflows, so work with our customers
to understand what their processes are,
what the data selections and technology
choices that they made, the modeling tools that they
use, and, and how they apply those to their
business processes.
Um, and, and I'm trying to be very high level
here without using too much industry jargon, but,
um, I, I, I again think that that's very,
very. Analogous across all industries.
We want to introduce then automation,
again, sort of respecting our customers'
technology choices and business processes,
so that we can eventually deliver some type of an outcome.
Um, we've been doing this since, you know, early 2000s,
first with physics-based,
kind of classical techniques. We've then layered
in, uh, uh, machine learning
and AI type models,
uh, and, and now we're adding agentic
and weaving agentic through every piece of this,
uh, of this stack as well,
so. Real
world application of AI, um, of
agentic,
um, so agentic enterprise software,
we're, we, we, we're taking very much
the same approach that I think everyone is. We're,
we're introducing orchestration, centralized
orchestration.
And uh where where I think our real
differentiator is, is again the quality of
our individual agents, the orchestration
agents, you know, largely sort of generic,
um, but where we differentiate is in our architecture
and how we approach these things, and, and the
quality of our individual agents themselves,
which we've basically taken Lucipa
capabilities, wrapped them up as individual
agents, and then contextualize them
so that, uh, so that.
In oil and gas, uh,
you know, you have a reservoir that that's 2 miles
beneath you, extending for some,
you know, miles into the distance every which way.
You have no means of actually measuring
what is going on under the earth.
So everything for us is an approximation
of the truth. It's uh you have a near well bore,
which you can measure. You have some
kind of mathematical ways of approximating
what happens very far away from the reservoir
in the well,
um. We need agents that have
some awareness of, of what the, what the
accuracy of their, of their prediction of
that you're always measuring the the
same value, but
you approach it in different ways. You need a, a
contextualized agent that understands the uncertainty
and the quality of the model that it used to
arrive at that
approximation.
This is where we're really spending a lot of our,
our time and focus.
OK, so.
We have our foundational
capabilities that that we call LIPA.
This is our physics-based models, classical
correlations, uh,
uh, that, that we apply.
Uh, you know, the oil industry has really
followed and, and followed along with
the sort of uh adoption of computing in
general, so,
uh, we have very simple plotting functions
to then as, as CPUs
became very prevalent, we had reservoir simulation
and, and nodal analysis and,
and ways of iteratively
calculating.
Uh, and, and simulating different things,
um, machine learning,
heavy adoption of machine learning across our
industry, and now again,
uh, we're, we're wrapping, wrapping all
these up and packaging them as agentic
into the shape of which you can see here is
the, you know.
It, it, it's presented as a chatbot
because this is the most comfortable user interface
that, that you can present to an end user.
Um, but behind the scenes, what's happening is,
is Lucy,
Lucia.
Uh, Lucy is calling onto all of Lucia's
various agents that we provide,
um, and contextualizing them so that we
can, again, reduce signal to noise
and, and present the right
context and call on the right agent
at the right time to service the right, to
surface the right recommendation to, um,
to our end users.
Uh, and, uh, so, so you can
see here, um,
everything builds on top of each other. So Lucia's
ability to go out and connect to data,
contextualize that data,
work with our customer stack in whatever
shape or, or tools they might have chosen,
whether that's on premise, whether they've,
uh, heavily leaned into SAS and cloud
technologies. We really need to be prepared
to meet customers wherever they are.
Um,
so, uh, you know, both on premise
and, and in the cloud, and all of this
is with the intention of, uh, of avoiding
just nonsensical recommendations
that are just adding more noise when, when
we're meant to be extracting more, more signal
from. OK,
so, so this is where I think we start to differentiate
is in our architectural approach, and
this is, again,
you know, it's a sort of forward looking architecture
but rooted in our histories. So,
uh, you know, the, the sort of gravity
of information, on the left hand
side we have the energy operator, our customer.
On the right hand side we have Baker Hughes
and our, and our digital platform Lucia.
The energy operator has, has a wealth of
information from all the different tools and, and
applications that they use.
They have their business processes that they flow
through.
Um, they have their, uh, their, their
particular operation that they apply these to,
and, and it's, it's very heterogene,
heterogeneous in the sense that,
um, every field that a
customer operates is generally different when
we go to talk to a customer.
We give them a demo of our software, they say,
OK, well test validation,
what you would imagine is a very generalized
process, standardized across the
industry. We start getting into the details
of how they do it, and they say that's,
you know, uh, that, that,
that's,
that looks nice, it's not how we do things here.
So what, what we very quickly took away
from that was that we need flexibility.
Uh,
across every side of this, and, and that's what
this architecture affords us is, is
really the flexibility of adapting
our agents very quickly to
the customer's choices and data sources,
the customer's choices and tools, and then standing
up some, some magentic protocols in
between so that each side can surface
what the other is providing,
and, uh, and then call orchestration
agents on each side to
um to both introduce uh
uh tools.
Agents and tools, as well as humans in the loop
to validate the response of those agents
and tools,
um, as they communicate back and forth. So,
we really view agents as a partner,
as a teammate here,
not as a, not as, not as a displacement
of human capital, but really as, as an
extension of human capital, right?
So,
to, to zoom in and get very practical
in what one of these use cases looks
like,
um. We
may have a customer who's chosen chosen
a particular flavor of reservoir
monitoring agent. It could be coming from a physics-based
tool, machine learning-based tool, but,
but that's, that reservoir monitoring agent
could be coming from a, from simple
surveillance of, of tags
coming off of a wellhead.
That reservoir monitoring agent should be,
should be tuned to uh to
specific conditions.
So in this case we're we're describing
a rising oil water contact, which if
we get too much water
encroaching into a well, we're going to forever
damage the well and produce far
more water than we than we want to over
the life of that well, and we will have effectively lost
the well. So
we'll have this reservoir monitoring agent running
on the customer side or on the Baker Hughes
side, but it's running in the background observing.
And when it sees some type of an event start to happen,
that it knows that we can influence with
another agent,
it will call out to Baker Hughes' specialist
agent. Baker Hughes, we, we really specialize
in, in manufacture and design of,
of pumps, of electric submersible
pumps, so they're these pumps that exist
2 miles under the, under the ground at the
bottom of the, at the bottom of the well bore.
And so we have various simulators that we can use
to predict, OK, I want to arrive at
what is the, what is the optimal pump
frequency or speed
or liquid production that I'm gonna produce
through that pump, so that I don't damage my reservoir.
And so it typically involves in typically
that would result in a, in, in, in a decrease
or slowing down that pump.
So Baker Hughes, uh, you know, our agentic
models make that recommendation of what we need
to decrease to, and then this
is where it starts to get very important for our
industry. So, in the, in the
application of AI and agentic specifically
to heavy industry,
um, we really need to lean hard into
having human in the loop, validated
recommendations by specialists who
understand the physical principles behind what these
agents are recommending.
Um, so we, we might have our agent
make a recommendation, but the quality of that
recommendation is gonna be wholly dictated by
the model that it's called on, the quality of the
data going into it.
And so our human in the loop just valid, validates
the sanity checks for it,
um, and before sending that then
back to the customer, right? So this is a service
that we provide.
Uh,
we send that recommendation back to the customer.
We are then passing that,
that customer is then validating with their own
human in the loop, the production engine engineer
who Baker is not able to in all cases
act on that recommendation itself. With
some customers want us to provide that
service, others want us to introduce their own
human in the loop.
Um,
so, it will, it will generally be validated
by, uh, their production engineer
on, on, uh, uh, you know, an employee
of theirs,
uh, who will approve our recommendation coming
from our subject matter expert.
Uh, and then they will then push
that recommendation out to an edge device.
Um, you know, we, we've really instrumented all of
our wellheads, uh, these days, so we
can push that recommendation out to an edge
device without necessarily needing to send somebody
out there to actually make that change physically
themselves. So this is, and, and then the cycle
just repeats. So then the reservoir,
uh, monitoring agent will go back to observing,
verify that the, that the pumps
change,
actually had the impact that we expected it
to. And uh the
process continues.
And, and
we have so many different agents and calculators
and ways of approximating truth
and, and, and quantifying uncertainty
that that this is a really sort of
generalized, this is one particular process, but
it really scales well and, and can be
generalized to so much of what it is that
we do because.
How do you break up a complex system? You, you,
you break it up into small little parts.
We have many agents solving each small
part of this.
And uh the orchestration, the higher level
optimizer of optimizers or, or orchestration
agent is really just making
everything work better
together. So
what we have learned through this, um,
and, and it's been very much the same learnings
that we've had since, since when we started doing
this in, in AI and ML and agentic
tools, uh, uh, you know, we're, we're
not really, uh, you know, we're really not
widely prevalent. So data quality
is everything, whether you're doing this with physics
models,
calculations, algebraic kind
of correlations, the quality of the data is
the foundation that, that you stand on.
Uh, the user experience, and
as we introduce more and more, you know, what, what
are perceived to be black boxes, uh,
the explainability of any recommendation.
Uh, or, or opportunity that we surface
is absolutely key. We have, uh,
you know, we have our users are, are
highly technical specialists who have
spent years,
um,
understanding like first principle physics
of how this pump works, of how this reservoir
behaves, of how to numerically, analytically
solve these kind of solutions. So we need
to be able to very, very at a very
low level explain, um.
Uh, how it, how it is that we arrived at any
particular recommendation. That was, that was something
that we were told from day one as we tested
the, the agentic concept with people.
It's just explainability to me is
everything. Um, adaptability.
So across the, you know, we use this term
heterogeneity to describe our reservoirs.
We have heterogeneous
organizations as well.
Every customer chooses different tools, different
data stacks, um, different
approaches, different business processes. Their,
their fields are all different. We need to be
prepared to meet them wherever they are,
um, on their own digital transformation
journey.
Um, and, and we work with customers, not
just in, in North American land obviously,
but, but global customers around the
world, um, will all be at different
stages of their digitalization, uh, kind of
process. And, and then the last bit
is governance and cost.
Uh, so
how to govern these things. HS&E again,
heavy, heavy industry has,
you know, disastrous consequences
of the wrong recommendation being made
because it's based on faulty data or stale
models or the like, and, uh,
and, and really putting
the guardrails in place based on Baker
Hughes's expertise is, is really one of the
areas that we, that we think we bring the most
value to our, to our customers,
so. What
makes it work, um, a lot of the familiar
AWS technologies that we know and love
and have heard announced and presented about
today, there, there's a, an open source
project that I want to highlight here called Energy Agents,
which is, uh, which is something that AWS
sponsors,
uh, and has released. You can go check it out on
GitHub. Um, so it, it shows
a lot of the same,
uh, techniques that we apply ourselves internally.
We build on these things,
uh, you know, data management, of course,
and then again, guard rails, which I've, which
I've mentioned.
So Um,
looking ahead,
again, this is where we look to
is very much again anchored in our past
of, uh, of
connecting to, contextualizing data,
uh,
you know, describing and working with customers
to describe their workflows,
automating manual processes powered by
these agents, and then of course using that to really
drive some type of an like an impactful
outcome.
Uh, where we have been doing this manually
with our, with our implementation
engineers, with our developers creating
these types of tools. We,
you know, I'm,
I'm speaking specifically about our
customer facing
LuciPA application today, but, but this is what's helping,
we see Agentic really is what's helping
us to really massively adopt
at scale the, the.
The technologies that we have developed over the
years, um, but are much harder
to roll out at scale when
knowing the level of tuning and customization
that's needed to really bring this to an asset.
So weaving agentic into how we onboard
our customers to then how we tailor our
workflows and, and adapt them to a particular
customer
need and then turn, create
a. And turn those over to customers so
that they can then in turn use themselves.
Um, it's really going to be the, the game
changer we believe in and what's going to
allow us to to really digitize this
operation at scale.
Um, we think it's going to be powered by, uh,
we think it's really gonna be
possible with uh and maybe
for the first time ever with agentic so.
I think with that, I am very much at
time and
perfectly on time, so thank you very much.
Um, and we'll be happy to answer any
questions, um,
we'll be hovering around there somewhere, so, thank you very
much.